hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice attacking game that was played in
the European Team Championship in 1980
yeah it's a game between Erica sparrow
and Joseph Preble he was a check
International Master uh I don't know if
he was an international Master at the
time but a pretty good pretty good bet
that he was he was um Czechoslovakian
medalist for for several years in a row
and he was a very strong player and he
was some 37 years old at the time
kasparo was 17 years old at the time
this game was played and uh it's it's
really an outstanding game especially uh
from a perspective of of a great
attacker and uh here Mr Joseph defended
very well but you'll see how difficult
that is I mean it's incredible I made a
video of this game some six years ago I
think where I said that kasparo really
played this game like tal but I decided
to you know refurbish it a little bit
you know uh I publish it at 60 frames
per second and uh well analyze a few
more lines back then I was just showing
games pretty much so let's get straight
into it and see why this game is so
spectacular because part of has the
white pieces and he opens with Pawn the
D4 we have Knight to F6 by Joseph and we
have C for G6 uh Knight to C3 and D5
Joseph goes for the groomfield defense C
captress on D5 Knight captures and pawn
to E4 now
attacking the the Knight here Knight
captures B captors and Bishop to G7 saw
a standard exchange variation of the
groomfield defense nothing spectacular
here Knight to F3 and now uh usually in
this position or it pretty much almost
exclusively in this position black goes
for C5 or kingside Castle those are the
two moves that are absolute main theory
for black today but here we have Pawn to
B6 by yourself and it's very interesting
how casparov plays against this Pawn to
B6 idea and the uh show what are the
weaknesses behind the idea as you might
encounter this move even even today so
here Bishop to B5 check by casparov uh
Pawn to C6 he invites black to go for
this move and now Bishop back to C4 and
okay now black does not have the C6
Square to be used for the Knight and we
have Castles by USF Castles by casparov
and now Bishop to A6 as the B6 Pawn has
been already advanced now he can trade
the light Square Bishops and he can get
his Knight into the game maybe Knight A6
Knight to C7 and so on but Kasparov
shows why this isn't all that impressive
and it is now in fact as of move 10 that
this position has never been reached
again so Kasparov captures it Knight
captures and queen to A4 now he's
attacking the Knight and the C6 Pawn
that's the the weakness that he created
and you could defend this with Knight to
B8 but then you pretty much bring the
Knight back so uh obviously he didn't do
that even though the engine says this
might be even better than the move that
was played in the game in the game Queen
the C8 was played now the queen here
defends the Knight and the the pawn on
C6 but for the moment the queen is stuck
guarding the Knight and the pawn you
will have problems connecting your Rooks
so here we have Bishop to G5 by Kasparov
going after the E7 pawn and while you
could defend with Rook T8 he also
decides to play Queen to B7 uh still
defending everything here now the queen
defends uh the Knight and the two pawns
okay the Rooks are now connected and he
has plans of pushing this Pawn all the
way E6 to prevent any future D5 ideas so
Rook if the E1 has part of continuous
development Ponte E6 and now Rook a to
B1 The Rook definitely belongs on a nice
semi-open file you do not want the Rook
on A1 and also the queen is on B7 so we
might be able to use this to our
advantage in positions like these and
now black just executes the move that
you always pretty much want to execute
in the groomfield and that is Pawn to C5
attacking White's strong Center and uh
no okay the queen also comes alive uh
it's it's a very nice move it's in fact
the strongest move recommended by the
engine and this is where the game takes
a really really spectacular turn because
power plays Pawn to D5 he sacrifices
opponent C3 to create a past Pawn now
how strong is this let's let's see what
happens in the game Bishop captures on
C3 now you play this uh regardless of
the position because uh if you don't you
have to admit that you missed the D5
which of course no one will do but it's
also the the objectively strongest moves
so Bishop captures on C3 Rook e to D1
now putting the Rook behind the past
pawn and E captures on D5 e captures and
now casparov does have his pass Pawn
he's done in material but his pass Pawn
should be compensation enough so brush
it back to G7 and now Pawn to D6
advancing that pass pawn and how do you
how do you stop this the queen and the
Roku guard the D7 Square so the pawn is
definitely coming to D7 and you can't
really put a rook on the 8 because the
bishop covers that square so your
options are very limited you can play H6
or you can play F6 now what would you
play here it's not easy to decide
because you know that F6 is very rarely
a good move it opens up your king to all
sorts of nasty checking ideas but it's
the move that you should play here uh to
give you an example if you play H6 here
then Kasparov has the option of playing
Bishop to E7 and if Rook after E8 then
you play Rook to E1 and already black
can resign there's really no a good way
to stop D7 and well even if you try
something like Knight the B8 then your
Rooks are no longer connected and you
can just pick up this Rook or if you try
Bishop to f8 this is possible a simple
Bishop captures a rook captures anyone
check Rook captures and Rook captures is
also more than enough for white Rook E7
now you kick away the Queen the queen
still has to defend the Knight on A6 and
if you play Queen to C8 then D7 and
that's it now black can you know resign
so what happens instead after D6 is that
he also finds F6 and it is the way to
play the position but now comes the
second shock of the game okay the pawn
sacrifice wasn't really that much of a
shock even a 17 Euro gas power was known
uh for for his aggressive play but now
comes the real shock of the game or or
so you would think and that is Pawn to
D7 knock as part of sacrifice is a full
Bishop back some six years ago or maybe
five years ago when I analyzed this game
I said that Kasparov played this game
like tal and definitely you can see some
some reason resemblances here so what
can what can you play here you can you
can capture the bishop that was played
in the game but even not capturing the
bishop wouldn't be all that easy for
black because because part of even
though uh he really idolized style he
really loved Tali as a person and he
really loved those games he said that
against today's modern Grand Masters or
modern Grandmasters of that time uh he
wouldn't really be able to pull off most
of his attacks and that's what they said
that took us part of about this game but
interestingly uh later on when now we
can analyze this game with very strong
engines you can see that all of
kasparov's moves are uh you know uh you
cannot refute them with engine just to
give you an example even if you don't
capture the bishop if you play Rook hate
the d8 which is the engine stop
recommendation uh there's the
spectacular Rook the D6 and now again
what do you play now black should
capture but even this is not enough
Knight captures and G5 and now there are
all sorts of nasty ideas like Queen to
C4 check followed by Knight to F7 also
Queen to H4 can be played going after
the H7 Pawn even with the best defense
from black let's say B5 Queen B3 checks
C4 and queen to H3 going after Checkmate
H6 you still get a grab hold of this
diagonal Queen E6 check and down after
King dh8 now you play Knight to F7 check
Rook captures Queen captures and okay
you've traded down a little bit you've
survived the attack but what the play
now Queen to E8 check is coming how do
you defend against this you have to play
Queen E4 and now after Rook beat to D1
as your Rook was hanging on B1 you've
doubled up Brooks on the D file black
will try to reintroduce the Knight into
the game now you play H4 ah beautiful
move the queen of course cannot move you
still have Queen to d8 track and you
want to have the resource of H5 also
creating some breeding room for your
king queen to F5 you offer a queen trade
Queen to E8 check Queen to f8 and now
the only winning idea Queen to E3 you
attack the Knight and there is just no
good move here for black if you react to
this let's say you play Knight B7 you
attack The Rook Rook the C6 and now
again how are you how are you uh
defending this if something like Queen
to F7 you need to guard the G6 Pawn
there's Rook the C7 you further attack
the Knight and if Knight to A5
interestingly the Knight Returns to the
square uh that we praised it uh for for
leaving but now Rook the C8 and even
after Queen to f8 now preventing this
just Rook captures Queen captures and
queen to E8 with check uh and that's it
now you can resign characters captures
white has a queen black doesn't that's
it this is only one of the lines but
just to show you how incredible this D7
move is and even if you don't accept the
bishop and G5 or even if you prolong
accepting it it's impossible to defend
but okay F captures on G5 and now comes
Queen to C4 check uh King the h8 and
knock as part of plays Knight captures
on G5 you could also
instead of going Queen to see a C4 check
Knight captures on G5 you could also
play Knight captures on G5 right away to
gain uh faster access to E6 but because
part of does it this way Knight captures
and G5 Bishop to F6 now attacking the
Knight and also guarding the queening
square which is very important Knight to
E6 attacks the rook and also adds one
more Defender to the queening square and
now again how do you defend this your
Rook is hanging can you save The Rook by
any means uh not really if you move the
Rook let's say Rook G8 then comes Queen
to F4 you attack the bishop and once the
bishop moves now you just capture it and
after King captures Queen the E5 check
you cannot capture with the Rook because
the Rook has to guard the queening
square so Queen to E5 check King F7 now
Rook the D6 this Rook the D6 resource is
key in pretty much all of the lines of
this game and now you are getting
Checkmate either by the rook and the
queen or by the other Rook even joining
the attack there's just nothing you can
do here we can play this maybe three of
the G8 Square for your king bro B3 and
now after King to G8 Rook to H3 and now
uh whatever you play let's say rotate to
d8 even Rook captures on G6 age captures
a rook the h8 check King to F7 Rook to
H7 checking to G8 and now Queen to G7 uh
with Checkmate so after Knight D6 uh you
also have tried to reintroduce the
Knight into the game so Knights the C7
was played uh but now Knight captures an
f8 we have Rook captures on f8 and now
Rook to D6 the only way pretty much to
continue this attack for Kasparov
and you also see why here Bishop D7 was
played it attacks the rook and moves the
bishop out of Harm's Way But now comes
the idea that Kasparov had in mind so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the only winning move that
wins for Kasparov uh while I give you a
couple of seconds and yes this is the
third shocker of the game
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it you probably tried all the other
moves and then you said all right if
there is nothing else then this must be
winning and most likely that's what you
did and you are correct and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Pawn to d8 promoting the pawn to
pretty much anything because you just
need to be up material but it's best to
maybe bring the queen into the game
which is what uh Kasparov did so it's
hard to make a move like this because
you've nurtured your Pawn all the way to
D7 you started sacrificing material
first you sacrificed the opponent C3 to
create a past bonding you sacrifice to
your knight on G5 to further start
advancing the pass pawn and now you
really want to keep it you know you
either wanted to become a queen or you
want to just keep it there uh to have
sort of an advantage for for the entire
game but that's where strong attackers
really really show us how it's done you
have to be able to always uh convert one
type of advantage to another type of of
Advantage here because Parov gives up
the pawn and he starts uh the real
Attack of the game so here uh d8 Queen
uh and also uh interestingly if you
don't do this if you start by Queen the
C3 check then after King to G8 uh you no
longer have this option so this is one
check you don't want to give now if you
play d8 Queen now Rook character 78 is
possible which will not be possible in
the line that will show because now
after Queen to C4 check King G7 Queen to
C3 check King j8 it's a draw or if you
track Queen to C for checking to f8 yes
you can trade let's say characters
captures Rook to D1 now the queen comes
into the game and the black is able to
defend this yeah but Kasparov played it
properly he played the d8 queen right
away and now it's different now if you
play Rook capture 78 you just lose the
game on the spot Rook captures Bishop
characters and the king is so far away
in the corner Rook D1 comes with Tempo
and now after Queen to f8 now you have
this option of Queen to F7 which would
not be possible if you allowed the king
to enter the game and now okay queen of
Fate is the most basic of Checkmate so
you have to stop this let's say Bishop
G5 now comes Rook D7 and now you are
either getting checkmated or you have to
give up the Knight on C7 so you don't
really care you can play Queen to G8 to
defend but white happily answer enters
this end game and this is a completely
winning end game for white so instead
after this queen upon the d8 move
promoting the pawn to a Queen Bishop
capture Sun d8 had to be played and this
is the strongest move uh Queen to C3
check now and now if you block with
Bishop to F6 look at this Rook captures
Rook captures and queen captures and F6
and uh again a rook against the Knight
completely winning so King the G8 has to
be played and now comes Rook to D7 again
keeping this queen and B7 keeping the
Knight on C7 paralyzing everything and
threatening Queen to G7 Checkmate so
Bishop to F6 of course you have to block
this now Queen to C for check King to h8
and now Queen the F4 interestingly all
of this had to be played in order for
you to get this position where you have
only one winning move and that is Queen
to F4 foreign now threatening to pick up
the Knight and C7 and there's just uh no
good way to stop the to stop this if you
move the Rook then Queen captures bishop
and F6 if you move the bishop then Queen
captures Rook uh there's nothing to try
but Joseph a strong player that he was
uh he finds a way to actually continue
this game he plays Queen to A6 and dark
as part of has to be very very careful
and I will give you one more opportunity
to pause the video and try to find the
only winning idea for Kasparov so have
at it
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on not being greedy
for the Knight on C7 the Knight did
nothing for the entire game it basically
only re-entered the game for a little
bit and then it still just does nothing
so don't don't grab that knight uh and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is Queen to H6 this is the
only move that wins the game this is
what Kasparov played and he was in this
position on move 31 that Joseph priebel
resigned in the game as there is nothing
more to be done here uh just for fun I
will show you what happens if you if you
greedily uh capture this Knight if you
play Queen captures on C7 look at this
queen characters on A2 and now Rook
captures an A7 checking G8 and your
attack is gone the bishop covers G7 The
Rook covers F7 you cannot reach this
black king even the black queen covers
this diagonal so you cannot even deliver
a single useful check and also you will
have problems defending the F2 Pawn you
have to play Rook F1 then Bishop D4 now
not much to be done here Rook to D7 can
be played and here it's uh it's a draw
there's no way for black or white to
take advantage of of any uh given
position uh because if you try a rook
captures on F2 then it's not a problem
just Rook the d8 with check and yes you
do have one Discovery but after King H1
uh not much for you to do here captures
capture so now if anyone's winning this
it will be white and on the other uh uh
well uh maybe uh if you don't want to
capture with the Rook you could deliver
check right away Bishop captures and
have to check but then King H1 and now
you're just dead lost here with black
there's no way uh to to to play this
you've removed your Bishop from this
diagonal and uh you you can't move it
back because the Rook will be hanging uh
so that that would be just losing so the
only move that wins is Queen to H6 and
now there is no defense against the
queen captures on H7 no move uh prevents
Queen captures on uh on H7 you can give
up The Rook then the bishop then you
give up the rook and then finally you
will have to get the checkmated
uh so yeah very nicely very nicely done
by kasparo like I said this is a remake
of a very very old video uh where I've
only covered a few of the lines but um I
I stumble upon this game once again and
I thought okay let's let's give it a
proper uh repolishing and I I hope I was
able to do that and yeah beautiful win
by the 17 year old Gary Kasparov uh if
you haven't seen my game in my video on
um kasparov's last game against Mikhail
tal also do check it out it will be the
first link in the description in the
description below as Kasparov said that
uh when talking about style even in his
last day he could play in a way that
brought him Immortal Glory uh so it's uh
it's a weird game because uh well I I
don't want to spoil it if any of you
haven't seen it but but do check it out
and also if I found a very interesting
video where kasparo was having an
interview with uh I believe it was chess
base India's channel uh or maybe it was
Summits or something like that where
they asked the Kasparov to share a very
fond memory of tal and then Kasparov
said that during his World Chess
Championship with karpov as yesterday in
the video we mentioned that Kasparov
became world champion antal's birthday
he said that he had one more game
against carpool and he if he did well in
that game he had a chance to become
world champion and in the night before
that game happened he received a phone
call or rather he received two phone
calls one from Mikhail botwinick who was
a former world champion and also his
mentor who and it was a sort of a phone
call where where batwinick would sort of
uh prematurely console uh consulk as
part of if he didn't uh win the world
championship title and he just wanted to
congratulate him on everything that
happened so far and that he was proud of
him and you know just being there and
everything and it was a really you know
a teacher a mentor student type of phone
call but then after that phone call
casparov received another phone call
from foreign
said that he sounded like he already had
a couple of glasses of wine maybe and
tal just said young man tomorrow is my
birthday and I expect a present and a
present uh he did receive
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and a bit of uh some
storytelling if you guys were not aware
of this so hope you enjoyed that as well
I would like to thank Bradley Peterson
Robert of sepian a Bowman Equity farja
de alilov and Richard Schwartz for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the Chess World so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and the may
we all play games like this at least
once in our life see you soon